the fbi gets reemed for calling
patriotic flags extreme
true according to the fbi every flag is
a red flag
[Laughter]
i came up with that
this week senator ted cruz questioned
fbi director christopher wray over fbi
training materials that reportedly flag
certain flags as being symbols of
militia violent extremism
i wonder if the flags included rather
astonishingly patriotic symbols of our
nation and our history
they included rather astonishingly
patriotic symbols of our nation and our
history
included on this list
is the betsy ross flag
now that's fairly remarkable that the
betsy ross flag in the fbi's indication
is indicative of violent uh militia
violent extremism
wow i didn't know betsy ross was such a
[ __ ]
by the way that's the uh betsy ross flag
in case you slept through history class
so what did ross do that was extreme she
sewed flags not dissent
look at you a little wordplay there but
it's not just the betsy ross flag
it's not just the betsy ross flag
also on this list
is the gadson flag
as a symbol of violent extremism now the
state of virginia has a license plate
for the gadsden flag as do many other
states
arrest them
the gatsat flag dates all the way back
to 1775 the year biden learned to ride a
bike
well what else was included on this list
also included on this is a texan i was
particularly struck
is the gonzales battle flag
come and take it well i will self-report
right now
that every day in the senate i wear my
boots
that have the gonzales battle flag on
the back of them
director ray
what are y'all doing
you know cruz means business when he
takes off his boots
it's the equivalent of adam schiff
removing his underoos
but was director ray familiar with the
particular document cruz had behind him
senator i'm not familiar with the
particular document you have behind you
we usually
make great pains take great pains to put
caveats and warnings in the document
that make clear
that a symbol alone is not considered
evidence of violent extremism
so in the fbi's eyes these flags are
symbols of militia violent extremism but
blm and antifa flags not included
but also included this one
thank god burning that one is
constitutionally project protected
or projected who cares joey everything
you wear according to the fbi makes you
a person of sexy interest
yeah you know um
i got a itch right here
a little bit of uh
so you got
you have betsy ross on one bicep and you
got the gatson flag on another yeah i've
got on my elbow so the snakehead moves
it's going to make a dance later you
also have really big biceps
well i skipped leg day i mean come on no
listen i am uh apparently i'm two-thirds
of uh well i'm two-thirds of a man and
also i'm two-thirds of a terrorist
[Laughter]
you're 100 all man in my book joey if i
get that gonzales flag tattooed on me
i'll get magical terrorist legs going
back
i mean how ridiculous is this and then
his answer is well you know the symbol
alone is not enough
no it's not enough because those symbols
mean you love this country and you don't
just fully trust the government and
that's somehow a bad thing like
we founded this country on rebelling
from tyranny we wrote a constitution
that guaranteed it wouldn't reach into
our lives and constrict us and uh and
now people that believe in that they
believe in those principles that founded
this country are a public threat because
this country is expounded to the point
of the federal government or nothing
like you have to believe in the federal
government to keep you safe that's why
they want to take the second amendment
away you have to believe in it so much
you don't need to speak against it
that's why they have all of big tech
behind them and it scares them to death
to have americans that still think for
themselves yeah you know uh
you might be familiar with this dr drew
so they do this it's like i call it the
criteria of linkage well anybody can be
guilty of something yes because somebody
else bad is doing it for example if you
drive a vw well you know who drew over
vw ted bundy and nazis yes no so just
it's just this weird world of
association yes yeah it's like
the volkswagen i think hitler start yeah
you're you're a nazi you're right and
they do all these these i saw a lot of
that in the january 6 committee there's
a lot of that stuff going on there but
they were saying it's possible that
there was maybe a
felony committed but since there's no
evidence of a felony how are the people
going to feel when a felony might have
been found right yeah and
it's like whoa these speculations are
all just associative they have no
relevance in fact and so what kind of
world do we live in well this is the
world of all the relativism facts don't
matter logic doesn't matter it's all
to you the white man that likes that
stuff and everything else is just more
feeling and political yeah you know cat
i think the fbi is in a pickle if i may
use that word
how can they infiltrate white terror
groups and foment kidnapping plots
against governors that they can't find
white supremacists
so they have to enlarge widen the net to
include joey yeah
i left a tip i left uh his name on an
anonymous tip line
you two yes
all of them yes johnny all the all the
j's just well you know what three j's
mean
i just i think this is why it's so
important to stand against the
surveillance state no matter how
hard the government works to try to
convince you that it is to protect you
and that's why i was against the patriot
act from the very beginning i know
that's something we argued about a few
years ago
against it once you give no once you
give once you give your government once
you give the government these kinds of
powers it's then up to them to decide
how to use them and they have to
convince you always your protection your
protection they can really truly use it
whatever they want it was wrong when it
happened to muslims in the wake of 9 11.
it's wrong with what's happening now the
whole thing is wrong they should not be
in our business the way that you know
they have found the ultimate way to
circumvent all of that is through the
public health system we call a public
health emergency
that's true racism is a public health
problem bigotry everything is now a
public health problem but they can have
unlimited powers when they when it's a
pandemic and that needs to be restricted
the courts need to look at that you know
uh emily maybe the blonde lady over here
is right uh we were warned about this
we were warned about this by the left
after 9 11. uh did they turn out to be
right that once you could once you
started looking for terrorists you were
going to be looking for
domestic terrorists too you could label
anybody yeah and i think what we saw in
that hearing is that the elevating of
what would be construed as
circumstantial evidence let's say in
court which means you have to put a
whole bunch of other things as a
constellation with that thing to make it
mean something it's been elevated now to
like oh this is absolute proof and to
your point in the intro there was a
total absence of any symbolism connected
to antifa black lives matter two
entities that have been totally
perverted while antifa from the
beginning that have destroyed billions
of dollars of worth of communities and
lives and yet noticeably absent
senator cruz also touched on with ray
the fact that there have been multiple
investigations conducted of parents
because of that letter sentence right to
the fbi he said yeah there may have been
small investigations and assessments
that's what ray said and cruz said well
actually we sent you oversight letters
detailing multiple multiple
investigations into parents that were
upset about crt and the the dilution of
their power over their children's
education and to your point you know
this country was founded on what was
supposed to be an inherent suspicion of
government the government should be
working for us not the other way around
and yet in between then and now it's
been completely erupted into this
bloated beast that we're just supposed
to sit down and take with unlimited
authority and every day that goes by
that authority gets bigger and there's
nothing we can do about it getting
smaller that's the problem is that the
you know it's like the beast that gets
fed every inch that it takes it's really
hard to put it back does the woke nature
of truth enter the courtroom around
evidence is evidence just becoming
associative now or the are the rules of
evidentiary procedures no they want to
talk about that
that has stated that it still holds yeah
no not for long
except
this is my show
anywho
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else